here's the closes yeah the first one the
applicant does not boycott Israel and
will not boycott Israel during the terms
of this
agreement imagine living for decades
under an open air prison where
everything you do is controlled from
what you eat to what you drink brothers
and sisters please donate as we have
come together one umah to get the
necessary Aid needed to Palestine and
Gaza keep them in your duas but
specifically brother and sisters give
from what you love inshallah and love
for your brothers and sisters what you
love for yourself donate now in whatever
you can and allow us to reach that Aid
with one um to our brothers and sisters
in Palestine one day palestin will be
free brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
the video we're going to react to today
might surprise you yes it actually might
surprise you because it surprised hijab
actually surprised thead as well they
were like no way and that's what hijab
says usually when he's shocked no way
and that's exactly the fact brother and
sisters did you guys know that in
America there there was h that hit the
country a couple of years ago yeah and
basically there were individuals who are
in need cuz they need to rebuild their
houses they need to rebuild their lives
but only under one Clause one condition
only go ahead let's watch for ourself if
your Texas house was destroyed by
Hurricane Harvey you can get emergency
funds unless you support the boycott of
Israel I'm not joking 21 US states have
passed similar laws which ban State
funds going to people or businesses who
choose to boycott Israel a country which
a recent un report has labeled an apar
tide regime and now survivors in Dixon
Texas filing for emergency funds have to
sign a contract stating the applicant
does not boycott Israel and will not
boycott Israel during the term of this
agreement the state government is
plainly telling its citizens that either
they get to keep their right to boycott
or they can get help rebuilding their
homes what kind of choice is that here's
a closet yeah the first one that the
africant does not boycott Israel and
will not boycott Israel during the terms
of this
agreement bro just think about that for
a second this is actually a crime of
thought you this it's what you think you
are being told that if you decide to
choose to not buy a product you will not
be helped so it's either your livelihood
your house rebuilding your family or
boycotting Israel and and I'm shocked
this is coming from a country that is
run by democracy you know uh and
liberalism for that matter and for the
fact that they're doing this bro I mean
what does that show you because to me
I'll be honest it just shows me how weak
and fragile Israel is that's exactly
right bro I mean for them to be so
insecure that they need to to arrange
these kinds of deals bro and in in the
heart of America as well where they they
Pride themselves of constitutional
rights and freedom of speech and freedom
of expression this might not be
technically against the Constitution but
it's in spirit definitely against the
Constitution strong aring these
individuals to try and do this but it
shows you where the weakness is they're
exposing where the weakness is and for
us as as activists or people that are
trying to push this kind of this kind of
cause then we know that boycotting
companies like Puma like seens like IB
is IBS
right IBM sorry IBM uh y uh star
Starbucks Starbucks
McDonald's the list goes on and even
like Jordan Valley days all these
McDonald's are empty now you seen yeah
yeah in in Malaysia Starbucks have been
literally reducing hours is the boycott
is working and I think that's the reason
why they're scared I mean for them to
put that in a clause when it comes to
finance bro bro it's it's it's a big hit
it's a big hit and we've seen that a
couple of years ago we done a little
campaign went to Tesco and people were
boycotting Coca-Cola and it was really
hitting them bro it was really and I do
you think it's going to come to the UK
where we're going to be actually told
that you cannot I mean what's it going
to be next you you can't get uh funding
for this or you can't apply for that if
you boycott Israel they have been
actually trying to push a legislation in
the United Kingdom which is um when
Boris Johnson was in charged they tried
to put um a legislation I don't know
what that basically says that local
councils yeah cannot boycott um Israel
local councils cannot do it you can't
make that up bro like you cannot you
cannot I don't know to what extent
that's actually gone through now but I
think they're trying to get to a stage
where it becomes illegal in the United
Kingdom for boycott to happen I mean
what does that say about their values I
mean what happened to freedom of speech
freedom freedom of thought it's become a
crime expression yeah I mean absolutely
bro exactly and I where I decide to put
my money or where to go to eat to to
have a coffee is my decision should
exctly exactly I can try and influence
you to do the same thing or to it should
be my freedom of expression to tell you
look this is a good place to go we have
reviews yeah we have reviews system we
have uh ratings you have smile to Jenna
and smile to dining and also Halal
dining remember you us go to
restaurants you know which is very
effectively why it's like it's people
saying that we don't like this place for
this reason exactly if we if we can say
on Google or wherever it may be that we
don't like this place because of its
quality of food or quality of service
surely we should be able to say we don't
like this this particular institution or
this business because of it's who it's
funding or who who's endorsing exactly
man it's it's unbelievable I mean if you
want to know who's in power brothers and
sisters just look at who you cannot
criticize it's very simple and clear for
that matter and it's very simple carry
on the boycotting it is your right and
the blood of your brothers and sisters
are in these products Jordan Valley
specifically a lot of Muslim shops of
licenses supermarkets are selling this
under the disguise and so much so I
think Zan by accident actually bought
those dates and I was like bro this he R
back out he ran back out bro the guy run
back out he was he was shocked he was
like how did surprised at the qu the
speed of the guy when he ran out the the
house as if as if he he forgot his son
out yeah yeah exactly I've seen him I've
seen him run a couple of times like that
before but the point is what if he can
fall for it exactly yeah tactical
Retreat so the point is this guys carry
ontical ret yeah yeah for them it's not
t ret it's it's a PO anonimous Retreat
brothers and sisters carry on boycotting
inshah it does make a massive impact and
they cannot stop us inshallah and carry
on doing that inah brother and sisters
may Allah bless you guys and yes not
only boycott their products brother and
sisters but it is incumbent upon us to
boycott our sins as well inshah um so
that's all I'm going to say till next
time from me and
mmed do not forget to check his recent
videos out on his channel in we are
doing an amazing work with Al's recent
videos which relate to boycot all of us
all of us Fring elements of our that
have attempted to try and say that this
is har which is absolutely ridiculous
unbelievable thing the true colors have
come out people I think this issue at
hand just showed you brothers and
sisters that some
people that's what I'm going to say
morals literally literally they are uh
what consistent uh was is it
strategically consistent not morally
financially consistent exactly
financially consistent not morally
Subhan Allah till next
time imagine living for decades under an
open air prison where everything you do
is controlled from what you eat to what
you drink brothers and sisters please
donate as we have come together one umah
to get the necessary Aid needed to
Palestine and Gaza keep them in your
duas but specifically brother and
sisters give from what you love
inshallah and love for your brothers and
sisters what you love for yourself
donate now insh whatever you can and
allow us to reach the aid with one umah
to our brothers and sisters in Palestine
one day Palestine will be
free